hey guys how's it going today we're
gonna answer some questions from you
guys that you asked me on Twitter one of
the biggest requests that I've recently
heard was just seen what has happened to
your theme song there it was I actually
forgot about it
I have a really really terrible memory
which is why I actually started making
YouTube videos in the first place
because I couldn't remember anything
that I had ever done
so I started filming it putting it on
the internet and here we are a lot of
years later so let's start out with some
of your questions the first question is
coming from Andrew who is asking when is
libby coming back oh don't you worry
this girl she's got some really big
plans
she's been really just lobbing around
being a lobster live in life but I think
she is a future my goal is to get her on
Shark Week that would be unbelievable
The Walking Dead wants to know how do
you pronounce is Erik and that's my last
name a lot of people don't even realize
that I have a last name or how to spell
it or anything
this is how you spell it this is how you
say it he's Eric sleeping handsome no
hope if I got my pasta bowl
I was watching Matt's video and he was
talking about M bows and how he used to
get pasta bowls or something and I don't
even know how this all came about but
then he filmed this video she get your
pasta bowl no I didn't get my pasta bowl
but I'm assuming that M bows got his
pasta bowl she get your pasta bowl Kyra
Kyra wants to know if I've watched
iCarly when I was younger I never
watched iCarly actually to be honest
with you because it was basically like
watching a Nickelodeon version of
exactly what I was doing on the Internet
totally fine I mean I'm well aware the
Nickelodeon basically ripped off me I'm
not mad and I'm a little I'm a little
I'm a little upset a little feisty on
below allow upset about it it's okay
that's life
I just in his Bay what's your favorite
Fall Out Boy song that one's like
do-do-do-do-do-do let me let me Spotify
it downtown I never knew that they were
saying that this is crazy
2007 or 2008 it's completely changed am
I going to know if I could choose only
three emojis which would I choose is it
raining this is Los Angeles it doesn't
rain here what is this what is this what
is this last photo in my camera roll I
think it's probably a selfie oh it is
it's actually selfie hurry up with my
friend bot --ax I met him originally in
Pittsburgh years ago you guys might
remember him he's also Wiz Khalifa's DJ
so it's kind of crazy because he's here
performing with him he was just on like
Saturday Night Live so bringing it all
back around Pittsburgh represent this is
crazy
Joe just asking me a question about my
book that I can tell people to buy the
book
it's kind of insane because the book is
almost gonna be released like the time
is almost here and I'm getting really
overwhelmed because there's gonna be
book tours there's gonna be so much
crazy stuff and I've been living this
book for the past year and a half so
it's kind of weird that it's now like
it's something that I can share with you
guys so I can't wait
you guys haven't pre-ordered check it
out I just invoke Tom pre-order save any
of the email confirmations that you guys
get because we review a contest that's
very soon and depending on what I post
this video there might actually be a
contest already running so good luck
June 2nd I'll see you guys on book tour
stay tuned for dates very very soon Oh
Michael Michael wants to know who am i
wary
I wearing the exclusive Walgreens Red
Bear so you guys probably have seen some
of your friends posting pictures with
red noses like my entire Facebook and
Instagram and Twitter feed for the past
like month has been full of my friends
posting red nose photos and if you're
wondering what that is on Thursday May
21st is Red Nose Day and Walgreens is
one of the official partners and I'm
really excited because it's actually for
a really good cause so you go into
Walgreens you don't need a dollar they
give you a nose and all of the funds
that are raised are going to help 12
separate charities to help young
children and kids in poverty
make sure you guys send me some of your
Red Nose selfies and be sure to watch
the NBC three-hour live special but
they're gonna be having it sound like
I've got a cold my best photo work all
right now see you guys later hopefully
I'll see a bunch of you guys on the book
tour and if not hopefully as soon I can
come to your city and it'll be really
fun let me know where you guys live so
hopefully I can come visit you I'll see
you later
hashtag Red Nose peace out